moins bizarre une histoire d'aurélia
moineau aux éditions epsilon édition
étoile endormi avec ta tête tu as l'air
bête et on n'est qu'à l'idée c'est que
c'est affreux ses couleurs
quelle horreur avec tout ce bazar
tu es vraiment bizarre moi bizarre sors
de chez toi et tu verras des animaux
bien plus bizarre que moi trompant tuba
ils nagent là-bas d'îles en îles comme
le crocodile
il voyage ainsi l'éléphant d'asie est
lancée avec ses pattes palmées et son
ventre en parapente
voici la grenouille volante haut perchée
déguisé en branches cassées bien
camouflée à croire qu'ils nous narguent
c'est le pot dargue il vit dans les
mares il a des palmes aux pattes un bec
de canard et une queue toute plate il
existe puis je t'en convaincre ses
l'ornithorynque pathé lancé tout léger
pour traverser les flots il court sur
l'eau aussi vite qu'un bateau île
magique c'est le basilic cesse en l'air
au milieu du désert sur sa carapace noir
qui lui sert d'abreuvoirs vient glisser
la rose et le ténébrions du désert se
désaltère cl en forme d'ombrelles imite
si bien l'ombre du rocher que les
poissons s'il est ce péché il est futé
le héron ardoise est caché sous la terre
accroché à l'envers ce minuscule insecte
sucré se laisse volontiers croquer
dans son abdomen que transporte hôtel la
fourmi amiel brindilles feuilles ou
bâton il les imitent à la perfection
pour le trouver ouvre bien l'oeil
voici le faste feuilles les doigts
écartés et allaient de la tête aux
pattes
telle une écorce toute plate ils jouent
à cache-cache bureau plate qui le
trouvera
comme une algue il ondule avec les
vagues dans la mer le vois tu sais le
dragon de mer feuillus et le plus
bizarre d'entre tous c'est ce félin pas
malin qui aime manger dormir puis c'est
s'est-il volet péché se camoufler rien
de tout cela mais pour se moquer il est
le roi
un vraiment de qui parles-tu je ne vois
pas